actually on a separate podcast but he
states that women need men
no matter how much money you make no
matter how much you can provide for
yourself a woman needs a man or she'll
die unhappy
i don't personally agree with that i
think there are plenty of women that
have made it on their own that have been
happy they don't need a man and his
point was you can't be
i'm trying to remember how you worded it
but it's essentially you can't be good
enough if you don't have a man and i
think that's just i think that's
ridiculous personally
um see i actually do think women need
men
no i think they do but i think to say
you need a man to be successful is
ridiculous that's the distinction i'm
not saying you don't need to be happier
you can't provide a loving life with one
another or you can't have children like
i'm just saying you don't need a man to
be happy
um see actually what i meant what i
understood his argument
was that
um men run a lot of like the industries
that keep society going so like if you
call a handyman it's usually a guy if
you call a mechanic it's usually a guy
so when he said like do we need men what
i actually thought of was like
most women like don't do those things
does that make sense there's some it's
just
i'd say like it's more the exception
rather than the rule can i can i say
something yeah
so i actually have a problem with that
argument because you know when it comes
to equal opportunities in education you
have to remember women didn't have the
right to go to school until like the mid
1900s right and
to it and also like now we have
what is what does that have anything to
do with me now
you know like so but the the reason why
a lot of women aren't certain
professions is because they weren't
given the opportunity
due to legal ramifications and
institutions right they couldn't you
know go into trade schools or they
couldn't go into law school and um title
ix was just recent was passed not that
long ago as well and you know that's
ensuring equal opportunity across the
board so i think that's why we don't
normally see people fix like you know
toilets and have trade jobs and all that
so are just women now i see it see i
would disagree with you because me what
a policy from the 1900s that doesn't
affect me today i just genuinely would
never want to be a plumber or a mechanic
or any of those things i have every
opportunity to go do that if i want to i
just literally would never want to do
that in my life
well i think the thing is is that
you might not want to but
think about it this way
we put in okay so when it comes to civil
rights with the black community right
they have been you know oppressed for
the longest time and brown v board of
education was passed to integrate
schools racially and we've had to
implement diversity quotas in order to
make sure that because these people have
been held back for such a long time and
it takes time for progress to ramp up
that you have to put in like things like
diversity quotas and you know
how would you know the difference
between people just like choosing what
they want to choose versus like not
being able to do that
so i like especially like like i think
like a quota you're gonna say like you
have to have this amount of people but
i'll give you an example i was in the
copier sales industry before
and they could never meet their quota
because women didn't want to sell
copiers it was a terror it's a terrible
job it's the worst job i've ever had in
my life
and so it wasn't necessarily that they
didn't have the opportunity but they
would hire pretty much any woman that
walked through the door because they
were so desperate for female sales
people at a big corporate company do you
know what i'm saying
so do you think it's more so the
marketing that goes into these things no
really
a terrible job i think like men are just
more willing to do terrible jobs in my
opinion i would have to agree with you
and i think there's a lot of women that
have they could go do those things i
heard someone argue with me yesterday
that there's not enough female mechanics
why would you want to be a mechanic it's
terrible work no
yeah like it's not that you can't do it
i've seen female mechanics but the vast
majority of them are going to be men
that are providing for their family
because they're willing to do that work
yeah
yeah my argument would be too you know
why would women want to do that work
i so i can't definitively give you guys
an answer right but like i think also it
comes down to individual preferences
right like maybe someone who likes cars
is going to go into like doing
a dirty job right and
like pearl and i aren't going to choose
it because we don't want to do it i
don't want to do it i'm i'm a little
princess i'm like i don't want to touch
this like ew right but you know i'll
gladly like plumb my toilet if i have to
or
but
i think it's just individual preference
i guess
but what i'm saying is right now there's
no laws in place that would prevent
women from doing that
like even the women the women that were
born today never had a law in place to
stop them i was told from a very young
age you're a girl you can do whatever
you want and me every girl i know not
one of them went into the trades because
the trades suck
and i don't think that's society i just
think like because if it was society
there would be a lot in place to stop
them if anything girls look like i think
they look cool but they have like you
know like their mechanic a plum or
whatever i just don't think girls want
to do it
do you think it has to come down to more
so
a financial standpoint because i could i
could get a here's the thing it's like
for let's talk about tech for for a
second like tech jobs are
grossly overpaid like you can make as an
entry-level director in marketing you
can make 120 to 130 000
i'm not going to change
yeah
and that's easy that's base and then you
also have comp and like a lot of people
are going more towards tech jobs and so
do you think it has to do more so with
the money versus like
women make ten thousand dollars less
than men
like on average and it's not the pay gap
it's the industries they choose
so like like trades make a ton of money
especially nowadays like i worked at a
plumbing place i didn't do it i was like
the marketing person but i'm telling you
those those plumbers had great hours and
they brought in cash
like
they were making like like i'm pretty
sure if you get a plumbing
apprenticeship they pay for your school
so you don't go into debt and you start
off at like 60k a year which is nuts for
like an entry like an 18 year old
so pearl's point too i heard jordan